today we're going to talk about some
really interesting information relating
to an autoimmune disease now if you have
an autoimmune condition
uh this video is going to enlighten you
on a a protocol that you may or may not
know about this information is about the
cohimbra
protocol by dr kohimbra he's a brazilian
neurologist this is what he said
all
or nearly all
patients with autoimmune disease
have an increased
resistance
to the effects of vitamin
d now we know today
there are
thousands
of scientific peer-review studies
linking the vitamin d levels to
autoimmune diseases so in other words if
you have autoimmune disease chances are
you're low in vitamin d but dr kohimbra
took it one step further and
found out that there's
not just a deficiency of vitamin d
there's a resistance to vitamin d he
noticed that in order to raise the
vitamin d levels in these patients with
autoimmune diseases it requires
much higher doses than in the average
population so for example if you're
going to
maintain vitamin d levels in a healthy
person
you'd probably want to use 10 000 iu's
and this is also based on quite a few
credible sources like dr michael hallock
who's the authority in vitamin d
discusses taking
10 000 ius of vitamin d
without
any chance of toxicity versus the
medical health care system in general
recommending only 600 ius of vitamin d
per day so when you give a patient who
has autoimmune disease 10 000 ius of
vitamin d3
you may notice only a slight partial
improvement so this topic is
very very important especially since
like 50 million people in the us have
autoimmune conditions now vitamin d
is not really a vitamin
it's a hormone it's chemistry is very
similar to steroid hormones okay that's
why it creates some very similar effects
to cortisol it's a very powerful
anti-inflammatory it helps to
calm down and overactive immune system
because one of its amazing functions is
its ability to act as an immune
regulator okay so it regulates the
immune system so if your immune system
is attacking itself that's out of
control and that's what an autoimmune
condition is whether you have ms
lupus rheumatoid arthritis
crohn's hashimoto's or whatever what's
common in all those conditions is number
one inflammation and a low vitamin d
status but my question is since there's
so much data
on this relationship between
low vitamin d levels and autoimmune
disease why don't the doctors recommend
this more often well i'm going to refer
you to
vitamin c in scurvy now in 1595
the world faced a serious problem with
selling ships sellers were dying there
was no cause no cure then in 1601 okay
several years later you have captain
james lancaster decided to give one
teaspoon of lemon juice daily
to a certain group of sailors
and all of those sailors did not die but
a good percentage of those who didn't
take it died like 40
so it was known back in 1595
that
something in lemon juice
prevented scurvy which is a very serious
deadly condition then in 1753
james lind published a study on scurvy
and he concluded a sudden invisible
effect
for scurvy when you fed
these sailors oranges and lemons now you
would think this this would be
disseminated and people would accept it
and the medical profession would welcome
this great information right
not quite in fact even james lib himself
said that it wasn't the vitamin c
primarily that was a secondary effect he
said that
scurvy was caused by moisture and you
had to keep these sailors in a dry
environment then in 1795 gilbert bain
persuaded the royal navy to give lemon
juice to sailors but it took 70 years
later
in 1865 before the intake a lemon was
finally recommended to prevent scurvy
but even that didn't convince everyone
so he was soon discredited for about you
know 60 more years until they actually
discovered
vitamin c so vitamin c was discovered in
now even during the civil war which is
1861 through 1865
7 000 union troops died of scurvy
another 45 000
troops died in directly of scurvy from
dysentery which is an infection that
affects the digestive system as well as
diarrhea i mean in 1849 when they had
the california gold rush
10 000 people died and then the irish
famine with the potato crops in 1840s
over a million people died of scurvy so
what is my point my point is it takes a
long time for the medical profession to
adopt new ideas
so with this whole vitamin d deficiency
linked to autoimmune disease it could
take
you know probably another 150 to i don't
know 200 years before they really fully
accept this and then you have in the
meantime people that will will stick to
this conventional
wisdom
even no
there's so many side effects because
the treatment for autoimmune disease is
mainly steroids and steroids give some
massive massive side effects and vitamin
d
does not and vitamin d works very
similar to the steroid cortisol but
without the side effect now when you're
using higher doses of vitamin d
potentially you could get hypercalcemia
and the biggest problem with that is
kidney stones however when we talk about
the protocol next dr kohimbra came up
with a solution for this potential side
effect
but we have to realize is that it takes
high high doses of vitamin d over months
to create hypercalcemia
so vitamin d is not really a vitamin
it's a hormone it acts like a steroid it
doesn't have the side effects but it is
different than most hormones because
hormones have a this very specific
target
tissue they go after okay like for
example the hormone testosterone or
cortisol or other hormones or even
estrogen they go after very specific
tissues but with vitamin d which i don't
even like to call it a vitamin
its receptor its target is in every
single cell of the body you have
229 different genes
that are directly influenced by vitamin
d which relate to 25 000 different
functions
it is the most important vitamin simply
because
it does so many different things and so
many people are deficient in this
vitamin now this is all very interesting
but there's something even more
interesting that i want to share with
you right now remember i mentioned the
term resistant right you're resistant to
vitamin d
one big way someone is resistant to
vitamin d is
a problem with the vitamin d receptor
okay
and
that condition is called vitamin d
polymorphism which is an alteration in
the receptor for vitamin d so in other
words if someone has this defect in the
receptor
they're going to be very resistant to
absorbing vitamin d they're going to
have to take a lot more than a person
who doesn't have this problem so to make
this simple to understand
you can look at a polymorphism as a
mutation which is some change in the
genetics now
this is very interesting okay you can
develop
a
polymorphic change
or a mutation in the gene
either through
having it inherited from your parents
or
developing it this life
from the environment spontaneously a
drug
a severe overwhelming stress
which could explain why so many people
develop autoimmune diseases after a
severe loss of a loved one or a severe
stress event or a trauma
so the more resistant you are to vitamin
d the more predisposed you are
to
getting an autoimmune disease like
diabetes type 1 and type 2
cancer bone loss
and even hives not to mention all the
other factors that cause resistance to
vitamin d like the color of your skin
the darker your skin the more difficult
it is to absorb vitamin d because the
pigment melanin blocks the uv radiation
which is kind of necessary for the
formation of vitamin d through the skin
then you have like the metabolic
syndrome or insulin resistance factor
which can block your ability to absorb
vitamin d
obesity the more fat you have the less
you're going to absorb vitamin d then
you have age the older you are the less
you're going to absorb vitamin d and
then of course we have the diet which is
even more difficult to get vitamin d
from the diet because there's not many
foods that will give it to you unless
you're consuming
fatty fish salmon cod oil things like
that and then on top of everything else
just not getting exposure to sun people
stay inside all the time they don't get
out there to get that sun not to mention
if they do they put a bunch of sun
lotion on on their body to prevent the
uv radiation all right so all that is
very interesting but what is the
protocol that's what i want to cover
right now now when doing this protocol
it'd be important to find a doctor that
can work with you and i'm going to show
explain why in a second
i'm going to put a link down below
of a website that you can help locate a
doctor that can work with you that knows
this protocol because you're going to do
a test for vitamin d before you start
but you're not going to determine the
dosage of vitamin d
by your vitamin d levels why because you
have this resistance remember so you're
going to determine the dosage by
measuring something else and that's
called the parathyroid hormone or what's
called parathorma when you take vitamin
d
that suppresses the parathyroid hormone
so the more vitamin d you take that gets
absorbed the less parathyroid hormone
you're going to have so the goal with
this whole protocol
is to drop your parathyroid hormone into
the lower level of the normal range now
if your parathyroid hormone is high that
usually means that you're low in vitamin
d or it's being resistant it's just not
going in now as far as the amount of
vitamin d that someone is going to take
it could range anywhere between
40 000 ius per day
to
200 000 i use per day depending on
a couple factors one being your body
weight as well as the parathyroid
hormone so typically the rough formula
for how much vitamin d you're going to
start with would be a thousand iu's per
kilogram of body weight so
i weigh 185 pounds
so that means i weigh about roughly 84
kilograms which would equate to about 84
000 iu's of vitamin d per
day now to minimize the main side effect
of this protocol okay which is kidney
stones what he recommends is avoiding
calcium okay as a supplement
as in hard water okay
as in nuts because nuts have a good
amount of calcium like in tofu or other
soy products which do have calcium and
anything related to dairy like milk
cheese yogurt etc and on top of that
you'll drink about two and a half liters
of fluid a day so you can have the
benefits of vitamin d
without the
the one big side effect which is kidney
stones and typically he states it takes
roughly about two months
to see the changes in the blood
consistently but then over the course of
two years you'd be checking the
parathyroid about four times and making
adjustments throughout and then within
two years once you're stabilized then
you'll be on a maintenance type program
now again this might sound complex or
difficult etc but from my point of view
if you have an autoimmune disease
and you want to weigh out the risks and
the benefits of being on prednisone
long-term versus doing this
i think it's a no-brainer so again i put
the information down below you can click
the link i'm not affiliated with this
doctor in any way shape or form but it's
great information for someone that is
looking for an alternative to the
conventional treatment for autoimmune
disease now if you haven't seen my video
on vitamin d toxicity
i put that up right here check it out
you